If you enjoy adventure, you probably want to experience a real jungle.
There is a perfect place in Brazil.
Jalapão, a state park in Tocantins, Northern Brazil, is a very new tourist destination...
...and one of South America's hidden secrets.
The area is loved for its amazing scenery, diverse flora and fauna,...
...pure waters, heavenly beaches, waterfalls, and friendly people.
It is one of the last places where nature has been truly preserved.
To experience a real jungle, there are guided jungle excursions.
You can see panthers, toucans, anacondas and capybaras living in the wilderness.
Your days will begin and end at a relaxed and comfy safari camp.
There are many activities that you can partake in: canoeing, trekking,...
...and watching sunsets from the dunes.
In addition, because trips are usually in small groups,...
...you can mingle with different people from other countries.
Just plunge yourself into this wonderful experience!